Stanford recently enrolled 16 937
undergraduate and graduate students and
concurrently list fifteen thousand seven
hundred and fifty administrative staff
nearly one to one in the past such
costly praetorian bloat consequently
problematic standardized tests are
damned as biased and pathetic content
diversity we have to destroy this
further what replaces it so you you
overthrow Putin and then who do you put
in there why make something that works
worse it's not the inclusion people who
deserve to be in the room we need to
beat down those doors and make sure that
there's no extraneous reason that
somebody can't get into the room that
they deserve to be in Via Equity are you
kidding me Equity is just this horrible
thing it's a trojan horse because it
sounds like equality the key point is
equity needs to die